[LAUGH]
Notice that most of the traits we see in the list here,
are things that I might even know about already. You know my ear
wax type, or my bitter taste perception, lactose intolerance. You know, are
are there any traits we can look at that I wouldn't already know?
>> Well, you might not be aware of whether you have HIV resistance.
>> Okay.
>> So and we what we'll, that is where we look at the CCR 5 gene.
>> Right here.
>> Well we learned about the CCR 5 in less than 6.
It says here that I'm not resistant.
>> That's right. So, it's going to look at your actual genotype and here it
says II. where the D indicates the deletion, the delta 32 deletion. So
people can have two deletions. They can
have deletion and the opposite of deletion
is the insertion. So you basically, I mean if you don't have the deletion,
you, which is called insertion. So you just
have both, two intact copies of the gene.
>> Now if.
>> And therefore you're not resistant to HIV infection.
>> So in this case, if the person, if an
individual needs two copies of the deletion to be resistant to
HIV infection, is this deletion or the delta 32 that we
learned about in lesson six. Would it be dominant or recessive?